- Hi Justin.
- Hi.
- It's Laura.
- [Justin] Oh hi.
- [Laura] Hi.
- [Justin] Laura.
- I can't believe it's been six months
since we've been talking.
And you're here right in front of me.
It's good to see ya.
Is everything okay?
- You just look so different
from your profile picture.
- I know.
That was actually about six months ago.
- You should update that.
- And since then I've
lost about 50 pounds.
- 50, Jesus.
- Partially because I quit
my job at Dominos so...
- No more discounts?
- [Laura] No.
- At Dominos.
- That's news.
- It's all part of my lifestyle change.
You know I had all those cats.
- [Justin] Yeah.
- I had to adopt them out.
- You got rid of the cats?
- Yeah.
- What about the pussy
party we were gonna have?
- I thought you meant like
a different kind of party.
- How are you gonna have a
pussy party without cats Laura?
Oh no, Laura not that
kind of a pussy party.
Geez.
You seem like a nice a girl.
But I'm just not into dating liars.
I fell in love with the
girl on your profile.
I wish you the best of luck
in your dating endeavors
because you're gonna need it.